still not convinced by the we use tablet
controller hybrid you're not the only
one the company has just posted a 457
million dollar loss for its fiscal year
I'm mark Walton and this is the news
nintendo's loss of 457 million dollars
makes it a third year of annual losses
in a row for the beleaguered company the
wii u which nintendo revised sales
estimates down from nine million to 2.8
million back in January sold just 2.7
two million units over the last 12
months lifetime sales stand at just over
six million units this stands in stark
contrast to Sony's PlayStation 4 which
despite being on the market just over
six months compared to that we use 18
has sold over seven million units in its
financial statement Nintendo said the
wii u hardware still has a negative
impact on Nintendo's profits owing
mainly to its mark down in the united
states and europe and unit sales of
software which has high profit margins
did not grow sufficiently Super Mario 3d
World new super mario brothers you and
new super Luigi u were all cited as
million seller titles but software sales
reached only 18.8 six million units
overall that's actually less than
software for the original Wii which
reached 26.1 six million units over the
fiscal year things were slightly rosier
for the 3ds which continues to boy up
Nintendo's financials with pokemon X&Y
proven to be the most popular 3ds game
of the year selling 12 million units
hardware sales reached over 12 million
and software over 67 million lifetime
sales for the 3ds now stand at an
impressive 43 million units despite such
slow growth for the Wii U Nintendo
remains surprisingly optimistic about
his future forecasting an operating
profit of 394 million dollars for the
year ending March 2015 it also expects
to increase wii u sales in the year
ahead but not by much the company is
forecasting 3.6 million in wii u sales
for the year ending 31st of March 2015
it expects 3d s sales to decline
slightly to 12 million you
the company hopes that the upcoming
release of Mario Kart 8 and super smash
brothers will drive sales another bit of
bad news for Nintendo then but what are
you guys think is it time for Nintendo
to pull the plug on the Wii U or will
the house that Mario built make a
comeback let us know in the comments
below and for all the latest gaming news
keep it gamespot